Bob clobber he joins us now New York
Newsday national football columnist and
the author of the book guts and glory
the story of three unlikely coaches look
at that Bob getting a walk up here he's
also the president of the Pro Football
Writers of America and he gets yeah you
can sit right there and you don't have
to put on headphones if you don't want
to yeah if you want your old school you
don't you want to go headphones here on
the phone all right so here's Bob
joining us now so the book is called
guts and glory guts and genius it's a
three unlikely head coaches who came to
dominate the NFL in the 80s and that's
Bill Parcells Bill Walsh and of course
Joe Gibbs all right let me start with
the cowboy situation here how do you
think this played out I know we like to
look at who won this did Jerry Jones
blank is a team friendly does he get
what he needed to get yes yes yes yes oh
really because I mean Jerry had to do
this there's just no way they go into
the season without Zeke Elliott and
there's the only way to get Zeke Elliott
is to make him the highest-paid running
back to give him the highest salary to
give him the most you know guaranteed
money they're beholding to him as a
running back now Jerry Jerry does things
like he's gonna get dak signed he'll get
a more a cooper sign he's signing all
these big deals
but you mentioned before about Jimmy
Johnson like you know if they could only
get along Jimmy would have been the
perfect coach in the salary cap year
started out you know I think one or two
years of that but he'd been perfect why
because he could draft players if a guy
held him up said yeah see you later
we're not paying you because the way the
system works is that we've got to you
know be cheap and reasonable and pay
only a few players now he probably in a
paid Emmitt Smith he paid he paid the
trip list you know Smith are of an
enigma but Jimmy would have been perfect
for this and Jerry is just you know he's
gonna pay big for big players but I
think he's gonna run out of salary cap
room at some point and that's that's the
challenge of this system and
Jimmy was perfect at it what is your
philosophy on drafting a running back hi
because the Giants are gonna go through
this situation coming up with say Kwan
Barclay they can't be surprised if he
performs they're gonna have to pay him
I think Elite running backs you can
draft high and and these are clearly
elite running backs now what happens to
the second and third contracts that to
me is what you know the problem that you
run into quarterbacks you know if you
win on the first contract of a
quarterback you're really far ahead
Flacco did it Russell Wilson did it any
quarterback who wins on this first
contract you're gonna be ahead of the
game and with running backs the shelf
life is so limited and then when they
get older you're paying that much more
for a descending player it doesn't work
so if a running back gets to his third
contract he's a Hall of Fame oh he's not
yeah it's very family yeah yeah cuz it
just doesn't happen anymore
also the next man up for quarterbacks
why is Mitchell true Biscay gonna end up
with more money than jarrod golf
why is dak Prescott Jared Goff just
became the highest-paid player in NFL
history why is it the next guy up gets
more money than the previous quarterback
when Jared Goff is not better than
Russell Wilson or or Aaron Rodgers but
that's just the way that that's just the
way the world how did they rig the
system though these agents to do there
there's the word the agents and that's
it
agents drive this process and the Union
drives this process the agents and the
Union are together illusion it collusion
but but shouldn't these guys get the
most money they can possibly get they
should but not every quarterback is
better than the previous guy right but
but that's that's the way it's been for
forever but I mean the guys in the 50s
made nothing and then all they sixties
guys why they make it all this money we
founded the league you know we then in
the 70s 80 you just any era that you
want the the newer younger players are
gonna get more money I would just say if
let's say dak Prescott is up and maybe
he signs in in the next week I would
just say we're not paying you Jared golf
money we're gonna pay you this is he
gonna be offended if he doesn't make
more money than Jared Goff
I don't think he would be offended I
think publicly he would say now I gotta
get I gotta get more than golf that's
just the ways but natural true Biscay is
gonna end up being the highest paid
quarterback at some point the NFL right
until Patrick mahomes comes along
correct and like all these deals like
wow if Golf is getting this what is
Patrick mahomes gonna get is he gonna be
the first two hundred million dollars I
think so he might be man I believe that
and you know what he'd be worth every
penny you're sold you me I love I love
Patrick ball you've seen enough that you
know that he is look he's not gonna
throw 50 touchdowns passing but he's
gonna come close and oh my goodness I
love his athleticism
I love his harm but I love his brain
because his brain he has football IQ
that is off the charts you know he sees
the field he sees what he has to see to
be this great when you combine that he's
got the talent he's got the arm and the
brain oh my goodness I'd this book that
you wrote guts and genius the story of
three unlikely coaches who came to
dominate the NFL in the 80s did you get
your copy I did yes I did and I try to
you know sexual we I think I first met
Bob you know these guys were there every
day with the Giants and I would come in
you see one day a week
Parcells was the coach so I'd go there
on the Sunday home games and then I come
in like on Monday or Tuesday and
Parcells you'd sit around this table and
you just hope that he didn't notice you
hmm
and he didn't notice me for a variety of
reasons did you get yelled at by all the
time yeah I once got a we can't swear so
I wrote a story about Lawrence Taylor
this was back in 87 he was drinking in
training camp so at that at that time
Dwight Gooden had the same problem and
he went back to cocaine so I had talked
to some expert to say that experts to
say that LT was running the risk of kind
of going down that road again going back
to cocaine so I had to research the
story I talked to LT i ad to ask him hey
Lawrence I'm writing a story about you
um I told me what I was gonna race out I
don't give up what what's your right all
right so then I go to Parcells parts
lt's lawyers gonna come after you hey
don't write it don't write it of course
I had to write it next they show up at
the press conference a very small room
at Pace University and I asked them this
you know some question maybe about the
offensive line or some you just got to
show up when your writes down oh yeah
you got to show up bill what do you
think about the left tackle position
looks at me he is that was a horse blank
story and your horse blank for writing
it alright you gotta sit there take it
did you quote him no no no but I like
you would have to now because it would
be all over Twitter and video but he
wouldn't have said it now because it was
just a different time but we we know we
we got to know each other quite well I
presented him for the Hall of Fame in
the meeting to you know give his
qualifications so I know I'll call Bill
Parcells all the time right now he it's
one of the it's the it's probably the
best person that I've ever covered
because of just the how interesting he
was and is and you're talking about Hall
of Fame coaches but different
motivational skills with all three yeah
yep very unique absolutely
we know Parcells you could see Parcells
very snide sneaky jabbing tried to
intimidate the media what were Walt Bill
Walsh and Joe Gibbs like well Gibbs was
much more straightforward than than any
of them he was just a he was he was a
grinder you know he was not a he didn't
have a lot of pizzazz as a person but he
got to players and he was brutally
honest with them Walsh was a game player
I mean he was a needler he would yell at
players through their coaches he would
yell at the assistant coaches but if a
player did something wrong and the
player would hear it and say wow you
know I don't like that now the assistant
coaches cover for him but it was his way
of kind of motivating differently and he
was he was he was a real game player and
and he he and Parcells you know those
rivalries Dan were phenomenal yeah I
don't think that someone in twenty-fifty
looking back at today's NFL would say
here's a book about three great coaching
you know the coke coaches and the rival
reason because you just don't have those
rivalries but they were they
long standing and Walsh was you know he
was just a game player and he was did
you imagine Walsh now and like who would
be more successful in today's NFL with
those three quarterbacks I think it
would be Gibbs
I think Gibbs was you can make the
argument that he was the greatest
tactician in NFL history sounds kind of
crazy
he was an offensive genius without
somebody labeling him an offensive he
was very you know he was not boastful
but he he won three Super Bowls with
three quarterbacks none of whom was
close to the Hall of Fame name me
another coach who did that you know
Parcells is close he won with two who
didn't who weren't gonna go to the Hall
of Fame yeah but you know Walsh had
Montana Belichick has Brady Tom Landry
had Stoll back Walsh ed young Walsh had
young you know it in the latter part and
you know it's he he won the Gibbs was
just brilliant and he he took what he
had and then he won with that so what do
you have in today's NFL sometimes you
don't have the dominant players you you
win with what you have you you know you
kind of put the pieces in place
well those coaches also like to say I
can item it's not the people I mean it's
not the player I can make anybody win my
system makes people win
well Gibbs did make people win but he
wouldn't say he made people win now
Walsh would say he made people win that
was him the book is guts and genius the
story of three unlikely coaches who came
to dominate the NFL in the 80s who has a
better season the Jets of the giant I
think the Jets okay have to have a
better season they have to they have to
just based on their talent I don't think
the Giants have a lot of talent they got
a quarterback situation
I like the Jets this year I like I don't
want to like the judge this year but I
do you should like the Jets there are
gonna be I think they're gonna be for
gonna be they have a quarterback who
gets it who New York's not too big for
them okay if you could stock in Sam darn
old or Daniel Jones
I'll take Donald okay I'll take door
I like Jones and you know so far he's
and everything asked of him but I think
I think Donald has a little bit more of
the it factor and he's got a bigger arm
if you know that you're gonna replace
Eli eventually mmm
why not just replace him now rip the
bandage oh yeah because I think they
truly believe that he's still got enough
and what you're not going any no I know
I know like if you're a Giants fan don't
you want to see my future we want to see
the future we know that's the past and
you show up to see this and it's sort of
Fool's Gold you might win a couple of
games and and how does that help you
well remember this Dave get him and said
several months ago to reporters at the
Scouting Combine we want to see the
Kansas City model we'd like the Kansas
City model what is the Kansas City model
they went with Alex Smith for one year
with Patrick mahomes watching and
learning and then what it mahomes do he
he takes off in year two so that's what
they're hoping and that Kansas City Mont
you know there is something to be said
for that when you when you and I started
covering football it was not unusual at
all for a quarterback to wait three or
four or five oh yeah right Sims was in
Jurek near make McNair Aaron Rodgers is
the outlier in today's NFL playing four
years behind a quarterback so the rivers
not for a little bit River Sat you know
with with breeze so it's I can see the
logic of it to some degree and and
they're both wired very well Eli's wired
to kind of handle the the mess that he's
about to walk into
and Daniel Jones is wired to handle what
he's about to walk into I thought he's I
thought he was very good he's handled
himself very well he doesn't kind of get
agitated and he you will not rattle him
very easily I wish you success it was
great to read parts of your book and
just take a stroll down memory lane
because if you're a fan of the NFL and
certainly these coaches and what's the
stat on the the coaching tree of
Parcells Bill Walsh and Joe Gibbs well
when you go back to Walsh's first Super
Bowl win in 81 to now 31 of 38 Super
Bowls have
by Walsh Gibbs parcels or the
descendants of parcels and Walsh
Gibbs's tree was barren but Walsh and
parcels created this coaching tree
that's phenomenal and and Dan 18 of the
last 19 have been won by Walsh or
parcels disciples 18 of the last 19 he's
Bob clobber of NF New York Newsday and
of course the president of the Pro
Football Writers of America guts and
genius Bob great to see you thank you
for thanks for having Dan thanks for the
headphones can I can I keep a nice
parting gift for you many many people
have worn those headphones enjoy for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]